let's go next to lucian from england
you're on the air hello david how are
you
i'm good how are you i'm doing well
all right so um so i saw that a few days
ago you responded
to a caller who was asking about the
idea of having conversations with other
public speakers like yourself but on the
right
yes um i sorry if you spoke about it
again since but i haven't quite caught
up on the vids
okay um you seemed fairly open to the
idea at the end of that and i think you
asked the audience if they'd be
interested
right um so my thoughts i've had
thoughts on this for a while wanted to
speak to about it because i think
i'm quite worried that people can become
quite insular and sort of stick to their
own kind so to say
and taking everything these people say
as gospel
and i wonder to what extent you think
this has contributed to the
polarization we see today you're saying
that maybe not enough conversations
between left and right are happening and
that leads to more polarization
yes and you you did say and i understand
that you said it's quite hard to make it
a productive thing
yeah maybe especially if you're trying
to speak to the likes of tucker
but um would you be sort of willing to
try it and maybe lead
maybe sort of like lead by example to
get the public to be more open to
bipartisanship
yeah i mean listen here's the thing the
call that i got last week from people
saying why not do more of the you know
kind of like blood sport type debates
with kooky right wingers
that's very different than when like for
example i had on
neil ferguson who's someone from the
right who we can engage in a more
meaningful way to hopefully try to
understand each other or like when i had
on
um who else there's a there's a bunch of
different people i've had on where it's
it's sort of more
uh normal in a sense i think that that's
great and i
have been doing that and continue to do
that i think that the question
from the from the caller was more like
more cartoonish debates with tim
poole or like the westboro baptist
church lunatics or stuff like that where
that i don't see as
as productive um but you know like when
i have
neil ferguson on or people like that i
think that that that is that is good and
i
plan to continue doing that yes
i i really hope it's making a difference
i just think both sides really love to
demonize each other so much
yeah i think if if the people we look up
to for
this kind of information if we see them
sit down and talk constructively
right and it won't fix the problem but i
think it could go a long way i don't
disagree i i i'm completely on board and
yeah my interpretation of last week's
question was more about
like the wacky right wingers where it's
just like you know how much do we really
look it's like funny to do
a jesse lee peterson interview but it's
kind of a waste of time too
of course yeah thank you very much all
right thank you so much yeah very very
good point glad to have the opportunity
to clarify and explore
further why don't we speak next
to uh oh i don't know i mean there's so
many different people
interested in getting on one of our
sponsors is susman
and han sussman and han has everything
you need
when it comes to face masks and other
supplies
to stay safe during covid19 and sussman
and han
is the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about
becoming a sponsor because their prices
are reasonable
ordering is simple everything ships
within 24 hours and they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers
face shields sanitizers susmen and han
is also an awesome company because
they've donated over 65
000 masks so far to health care
institutions
shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars you can go to
their website by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you 20
off when you use the coupon code david